مرشحوا المعارضه الخاسر كمال كليتش دار
اوغلو اعتبرها عمليه انتخابيه غير عادله
تم تسخير امكانيات الدوله للفائز الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان الرجل الذي اثبت
انه لا الانقلابات الفاشله ولا التضخم ولا
الزلزال ولا انتخابات ديمقراطيه قادره على
حرمانه من ولايه ثالثه في حكم تركيا نسي
الاتراك ازمتهم الاقتصاديه لليله واحده
[موسيقى]
ليله غنى فيها الرئيس اردوغان مع مناصريه
عقب اعلان فوزه بخمس سنوات اخرى في السلطه
فوز تباينت بشانه اراء الشارع كما تباينت
اصوات الناخبين
انا ارى خيرا في هذه النتائج ان شاء الله
الموجود ليس تنظيما ارهابيا بالمرشح
انتخبه الشعب لاداره الدوله الوعود التي
اطلقها الطرف الاخر كانت محفزه لنا كي لا
ننتخبهما
قبل فكره تغيير نظام الحكم نحن نريد حقوق
الاكراد وان يكون لنا الحق في ابداء الراي
لذلك دعمنا حزب الشعب الجمهوري بالعموم
انصار الحزب لم يدعمه بشكل كافي الشارع
التركي استفاق على نفس المشاكل الاقتصاديه
وغلاء المعيشه فرغم مباهات انصار اردوغان
بما قام به من دعم لمكانه اولاده في
الخارج ومواقفه المتشدده من الارهاب يظل
العامل الاقتصادي مؤثرا على الجميع خاصه
مع تراجع الليره التركيه غداه اعلاني
نتائج الانتخابات
ليكون هناك استقرار وليتقدم تركيا الى
مكانات افضل الرجل يعمل يصنع مدافع
الطائرات الحربيه يصنع طائرات مروحيه يشق
الطرق ويبني المستشفيات انه يعمل
مساء امس كنا سعداء جدا
فاز
وبالرغم من كل هذه الاحتفالات تبدو فكره
الوحده في هذه البلد
المستقطب ابعد من اي وقت مضى فخمسه وعشرون
مليون تركي صوتوا ضد اردوغان الذي يدخل
فترته الرئاسيه الجديده متمتعا بسلطات
واسعه غير مسبوقه كانت معكم موفده العربيه
راويه القاسم من مدينه اسطنبول التركيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات